I'm tired of Secrets so I'm glad we're
here I need to root out all the secrets
hey youtubers is Charlie agents of
shield just served up the newest super
villain for Marvel Canon it also had a
Winter Soldier slash Wizard of Oz
crossover there was something about a
zero eight four mmm quick heads-up
before we get started though agents of
shield is gonna be on break for a couple
of weeks just for the Olympics but the
next episode when we come back is gonna
be the Stan Lee cameo episode it'll be a
much bigger cameo than what he does in
the movies be sure to subscribe to get
my video it's gonna be a lot of fun I
can't wait to see what craziness he's up
to
okay careful for spoilers from seeds if
you haven't seen the episode yet I know
a lot of you in the UK don't see it till
a week after but we're gonna start with
our top five moments then I'll do my
review and I'll kind of explain how the
episode is integrated with winter
soldiers plot number five clairvoyant
shout out Ian Quinn is working for the
clairvoyant it was a bit of a surprise
to see him again but I can see them
wanting to keep the number of guest
stars down so it makes sense that they
would use Quinn as like the Justin
Hammer stand-in in this episode it's
pretty clear that the clairvoyant is the
big bad now and I think that given Sky's
past at least what we know about it now
she's gonna become a target at some
point number four sky 0-8 for that
actually sounds like real radio jargon
so sky was classified as an unknown
object as the baby in China she has
special powers but they didn't really
explain what they are
I'm really hoping they don't wait till
the finale to reveal them though because
it would be really cool to see her to
use some special powers her arc in the
episode ties in with the Winter Soldier
too many secrets themed either way we
can all start guessing who her real
parents are started thinking of all the
Chinese superheroes you know number
three main Coulson brought out in Mexico
my favorite scene from there you know
kind of bro trip was Coulson finishing
this epic speech about needing to get
rid of all the secrets and the camera
pans over Ismay reveals that she's been
boning Ward and Coulson just runs off
and leaves her there funniest scene in
the episode hands down later may paid
off the joke again when she said that
she'd ended if it became a problem the
way she said it made it seem like you
know ending it meant killing Ward that's
not what she meant but my mind jumped
there instantly and I laughed pretty
hard
number two the Winter Soldier crossover
it was a very light crossover but there
was a reference to Bucky Barnes on the
memorial who's a big part of the Winter
Soldier plot and thematically shield
started to set up the culture of Secrets
that's going to drive the movie the
title of the episode seed refers to the
seat of evil growing inside of shield
Closen kind of explained it with a few
lines there are too many secrets we need
to learn what they are that's basically
what Captain America is going to be
doing during the movie he's on one side
Robert Redford is on the other shield is
central to the plot of Winter Soldier so
I think people would have been really
pissed if the TV show didn't somehow
acknowledge the cancer that's eating
shield from the inside out right now the
real question we need to ask is will the
clairvoyant be part of the movie or will
they resolve that threat during the
finale of the TV show the finale of the
TV show is actually happening the same
time the movie is premiering so I'm
really hoping those two plots collide
and my number 1 moment Donnie Gill aka
Blizzard he's the new super villain on
the show now so this episode was
something of an origin story for him he
mostly appeared in the Iron Man comics
and he worked for Justin Hammer he was
actually the second person to use the
name blizzard what I'm hoping is is that
before the finale the clairvoyant is
going to stage you know something about
jailbreak on all the super villains
shield has captured since episode 1
interestingly enough the prison they
were talking about last week was called
the fridge so I definitely think we'll
be seeing Donnie again this season can
you just imagine that line repeat the
blizzard has escaped the fridge repeat
the blizzard has escaped the fridge let
me know what your favorite moment was
though was it seeing another
supervillain was it learning the
clairvoyant was behind everything you
know was it learning about Skye's past
overall I thought the episode made good
use of Marvel Canon and integrated
itself nicely with what's going to
happen in Winter Soldier later this year
the pacing was a little slow but I got
so much more excited about the sky'
character whenever Coulson learned the
truth so I'm really happy that character
is going somewhere
speaking of which Coulson and May by far
the winningest two actors in the episode
Fitz dominated the other half of the
episode and he had some great comedic
beats but I was really having a hard
time connecting with him as a lonely
student the character is still so new
it's gonna be a couple of seasons before
he feels like he's my best friend
all Whedon based shows have amazing
characters but you can only connect with
so many people right away on that note
right your favorite Joss Whedon
character in the comments below it
doesn't have to be from agents of shield
technically agents of shield isn't a
Joss Whedon show he's just loosely
involved with it so remember no agents
of shield for the next two weeks just
because of the Olympics but Stanley is
going to bring the show back whenever it
does come back so it's gonna be a lot of
fun be sure to
great to get my video from that also
remember arrows coming back tomorrow
it's gonna be an awesome second half of
the season I cannot wait to see Slade
Wilson right now click here to get last
week's agents of shield and click here
to get my top ten predictions for arrow
the second half of this season thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives
you